pourquoi les animaux sur certaines îles
sont gigantesques on appelle ça le
gigantisme insulaire c'est quand une
espèce isolée sur une île devient géante
comme le dodo comment en est-on arrivé
là pour les petits carnivores pas de
concurrence c'est buffet à volonté donc
il s'engressissent pour les petits
herivores plus besoin de fuir rapidement
ou se cacher des prédateur ils peuvent
donc grossir sans contraintre à
l'inverse il existe le manisme insulaire
un diplodocus qui devient un
magiarosaurus plus petit qu'un cheval
pourquoi l'exacte inverse c'est qu'une
espèce très grosse les généralement pour
intimider les prédateurs ou atteindre de
la nourriture en hauteur si c'est pas
utile elles vont rapétisser comme sur
une île pour les carnivores eux ça
serait le manque de proie il faut
réduire sa consommation donc ça taille
voilà donc